okay how much video oh I'll get that off
okay notice you're stuffing my beard oh
by the way this is a friend of mine for
free
hi I'm Steve Rogers
don't close his fists
[Music]
[Music]
you
violence is closed today
you better pack it up and get out of
here
stem Kiba does this chattering animals
speak for you
certainly not I speak for myself
trespassing in this city and on this
planet Wow where's your guy I don't know
everybody having a thing it's no time
for a thing that's the thing right there
let's go
[Music]
dude your bears to me from the Wizards I
can't stand down
are you yawning in the middle of this
while I'm breaking it down huh did you
hear what I said
stop listening after you said do we need
a plan
okay mr. clean is on his own page see
not winging it isn't really what they do
what exactly is it that they do kick
names take ass
all right just get over here please mr.
Lord can you get your folks to circle up
mr. Lord star-lord is fine
we gotta coalesce cuz if all we come at
him with us a plucky attitude dude don't
call us plucky we don't know what it
means
all right we're optimistic yes I like
your plan except it sucks so let me do
the plan and that way it might be really
good
I'm gonna asked one time who are you
you're the Avengers man Thanos
if he gets all the Infinity stones
he'll wipe out half the universe
everything you know everything you love
it will all be gone just like that
well he's never Ford me yeah he has he's
never fought me twice getting new hammer
better be some hammer he's coming to us
I say we take the fight to him
[Music]
you guys are screwed
[Applause]
[Music]
oh by the way this is a friend of mine
tree hi I'm Steve Rogers
together we can stop
[Music]
where's your guy
dude you're embarrassing me from the
wizard
you